[Música]
é eu sou terapeuta já foi dito sobre a
vida e se aumenta só fé da felicidade
a felicidade é uma palavra mágica só de
ouvirmos esta palavra como dissemos é
subir muito bairro é algo tão mágico que
todas as pessoas todas gostariam de ter
uma vida do elemento fui questão é e
seguinte
se todos querem ser felizes porque tem
um pouco do céu
qual é o segredo
isto tem sido alvo de muitos estudos em
várias universidades do mundo é estuda
se o qual é o segredo da felicidade a um
destes estudos que eu gosto particular
nelas e este estudo vai rolar
qual é o segredo da felicidade
hoje eles saíram daqui iremos todos com
essa informação
quer saber
foi feito um estudo durante vários anos
muitos anos um grupo de pessoas pessoas
solteiros casados pessoas que tenham
filhos ou os que não tenham filhos
artistas canalizadores empregados fabris
pessoas com muito dinheiro e pessoas que
não tinham nada na vida
o que este estudo revelou revelou que o
segredo da felicidade é sermos nós
próprios
uau agora já sabemos mas nós vamos nós
o álbum pergunta não
nós não somos nós próprios
nós estamos vivemos mais ou menos como
os robôs sabem como é que os vivem com
um mando como existia mesmo comendo pais
família religião
chama-se sociedade amigos
nós temos este comando e acreditamos que
só podemos beber vez neste comando como
se não fosse possível ter vontade para
abrir a nossa vida é mais ou menos como
a vida do leãozinho que foi criado com
as leis e os sei que muitos dos que
estão aqui presentes conhecem essa
história mas eu vou guardar uma vez de
mel e ou é foi a graça e chegou um certo
lugar onde havia muitas ovelhas ela
ficou muito emocionada e o vavá o
irmãozinho no boca e deixou cair e foi a
correr com as ovelhas para acostagem
neste momento 11 e ficou abandonada e
foi criado pelas ovelhas e quando
ilsinho que chegou eu queria comunicar
se e fazia o que vinha a mãe ou velha
dizia isso não se faz
quando quisemos falar disso e sim que
deve rolar mas o leão não conseguia
entender isto porque é natureza dela o
que vinha de dentro era fazer mas eu não
estou porque eu tenho
um dia eu estava com as ovelhas e de
repente apareceu um leão e consegue tudo
fugiriam parceria com silvio também iam
disso é esperado
aí é igual a mim
selma explodir nem ataca xto não foge a
esta história faz lembrar as consultas
quando aparecem show entre as ruas
wilson lindíssimas e majestoso foliões e
sabe como é que eles falam
eu tento já dos jurados acreditamos
somos 20 mas esquecemos que somos
protagonistas
nós não somos ovelhas nós são os leões e
conseguimos acreditar que nossa vida
dependo dos outros e só podemos ser
felizes
se os outros fizerem isto ou aquilo
meu querido fizer assim eu você foi isso
se os meus filhos estiverem bem e você
fluir
quando eu comprar uma casa eu vou ser
feliz ou seja que felicidade
dependendo daquilo que os outros façam
e depois história nessa nossa verdade
pois é assim que nós vemos a nossa vida
pudesse mudar nada
isso faz lembrar uma história muito
curiosa que o do futuro papel santandreu
é conta no seu livro se fossem alasca
que aconselho a lerem estou indo eu
explica ou em um corda que é um jovem
médico que no seu primeiro dia de
trabalho visitam é sua amiga e então eu
caminhar pelo passeio para conhecer os
corredores e e tudo isto você não pelo
flash é e essa pedra começou a ouvir
alguém vai acompanhar por outro médico e
começou a ouvir alguém que existe
uau a loa iam perguntou o que se passa
com este homem era um amor impossível
lux eu porque nunca conseguiu casar com
ela e ela dá um ficou louco e agora
passa a vida a chamar pelo nome dela eu
caí tabaí continuaram e mais à frente e
começou a ouvir alguém que gritava como
um louco também estava muito este homem
sofre pela mesma mulher eo médico
respondeu ele sim mas isso ficou louco
porque casou com ela com certeza
conhecemos muitas pessoas que também
vivem assim suas que dizem se isto ou
aquilo acontecesse eu seria fluir mas a
felicidade não dependo dos outros
perfumes e simples quando nós aceitamos
que só nós temos a chave da felicidade
para aquilo que o estudo dizia para eu
ser feliz
eu tenho que ser eu própria
como é que alguém pode ser o próprio se
não só quem já pararam que a maior parte
das pessoas não sabem é que tudo isto
perguntar às pessoas quais são as duas
paixões mais fácil é quais são as suas
qualidades ou sei lá então e tem algum
defeito nos conhecemos conhecemos o
nosso próprio modelo básico está lá eo
cara não serão excluídos temos que nós
próprios temos que saber quais são os
nossos sonhos
quais são as nossas paixões quais são os
nossos defeitos quais são as nossas
qualidades
o que eu gosto de fazer isso até parece
que estava combinado por 500 mil vieram
várias pessoas falar sobre as suas
paixões e se perguntarem estas pessoas
relaxam luis scola que são fluentes
nunca vivi aquilo que gosto de fazer
seja o que for
ninguém tem que ser igual a ninguém
todos somos fantásticos e maravilhosos
mas se permitirmos que outras coisas se
metam na nossa vida e nós usarmos como
desculpas para não sei onde foi isso aí
já é mais complicado
uma vez um mestre samurai caminhada dura
uma amiga bonita que poderia ser mais ou
menos é aquela que temos no nosso
distrito
é eu caminhava com o seu fiel discípulo
e de repente ao longe deve estar uma
casa
persista destruída
olha eo mestre diz olha vamos visitar
aquela casa
vamos ver se igual é porque este é o
lugar está tão longe de tudo que se viu
alguém aí ter alguma dificuldade em
sobreviver
e de facto aconteceu isso chegaram
encontraram um lugar completamente
destruído uma casa que tem apenas uma
maneira é odiado estava que ir
havia crianças não estavam todos rotos
maus filas estavam o senhor isso era
então eu chegou cumprimentou família e
perguntou como é que vocês vivem neste
lugar de tão longe do dom e olhe se sabe
senhora
nós temos uma vaca
ela dá vários litros de leite por dia
então o que nós fizemos uma parte quero
minhas várias horas e vamos as idades e
trocamos por outros alimentos e e outra
parte como tripulantes fazia o shakhtar
juve fazendo outras coisas e alimentar
um dia desta forma conseguimos viver
sobreviver agradeceu e foi embora e
quando chegou assim longe ou do olhar
para trás eles vai àquela casa ceni é
dever e matar vaca
chico como é que eu vou fazer isso
como é que eu vou matar o único meio de
sobrevivência desta família vai me matar
disse que não sabia que o mestre era
sábio e foi e cumpriu as ordens mas
durante muitos anos não conseguiu dormir
com que o peso na consciência
a única forma de sobrevivência desta
família então o que eu fiz tenham
passado vários anos e um civil e visitar
a família e saber o que se passava e
pedir prisão quando já estava a
aproximar se em vez de uma casa velha
viu uma casa nova
flores estavam a crianças estavam
bairros china compensou certeza família
morreu e vieram para cá outras pessoas
ainda mais preocupadas quando chegou
perguntou assim a costa
a desculpa que ela família morava cá uns
anos atrás o que aconteceu
somos nós que estamos muito vai e alstom
vai sim estamos miley vai cortar
nós tínhamos uma vaca mas alguém vai
cair foi antonio a faca ea partir daí ó
tivemos que nos virar a vida e tivemos
então que por serem quem eram os bons
para conseguir criar negócios e ó
descobrimos os nossos dons e hoje temos
um macho lento condição como v
temos uma casa nova
[Música]
vou fazer uma pergunta seja sincero na
sua vida até alguma vaca
já vi que sim
precisamos descobrir quais são os nossos
dons viver nossas paixões
não temos que imitar ninguém nem temos
que ter obstáculos na nossa vida ser
feliz não estar sim por saltos e que
tudo corra tem isso não é ser feliz
a felicidade estamos satisfeitos com
nossos próprios e aceitar os outros como
eu são tendo um tem o seu ponto de vista
que não é fluido à sua maneira
gostaria que a partir de hoje
escrevessem no papel todas as nossas
qualidades
todos os vossos sonhos em que gostariam
de trabalhar e como é que gostariam que
fosse o vosso billy aula que também é
que de tarde da noite
as pessoas que não fazem isso não sabe o
que acontece é vida passa isolado porque
estão sempre à espera que aconteça como
que os ames que criam que usar cola não
faça isso na sua vida se tiver uma vaca
que esteja checchia
conforme e eu vou lá e judah metal ser
por isso e símbolos
obrigada
[Aplausos]